do you feel in love right now like a
little bit okay and then would you
understand uh searching for love yes and
you understand like
almost a disappointment around it would
that be correct yeah I would just want
you to say for me I am in love I am in
love I want you to say for me I want
love I want love I don't feel like
you're married I feel like you're single
I feel like you're single and I feel
like there is someone around or was
someone around so I'm single but I
recently met someone on vacation okay
when he comes to see you just let
yourself try to relax around it you are
nervous about it and in a good way I
want you to be open to him all right so
good luck with this okay